the defenders I am digging it for
episodes in so I'll come back when I see
the back for and let you all know what I
think then
Oh
what offenders second half of the first
season boys at that nosedive
spectacularly
so that's your spoiler free version I'm
talking about the second half of the
season and I'm going to get into details
so we're getting into spoilers pretty
much right off the bat I'm not going to
break this down episode by episode I'm
going to jump around I might mention an
event and then peg it in the wrong
episode because honestly these last four
kind of blurred together for me a little
bit but basically everything fell apart
in episode six
so boy where do we start here um you
know what before I get into all my
bitching let me reiterate a few good
things so the lead altogether
had good chemistry played well off each
other
surprisingly Danny Rand and Luke Cage
played especially well off each other
which is good so hopefully they'll build
off that with their respective series
because the you know definitely Danny
Rand on his own didn't work he works
much better playing off of Luke Cage
there were some more very good fight
scenes there were also some more very
bad poorly lit excessively cut fight
scenes as well it
I didn't bother counting but I wish I
kept a tally of every good fight scene
and every bad fight scene because I am
pretty sure it was a 50/50 split by the
time the thing wrapped up so again
overall the team dynamic worked pretty
well for the most part they certainly
played well enough off each other I
would like this to get another season I
would like to see these four brought
together again to tell a better story
than this so let's do let's get into
this and start getting into the
specifics of what does not work okay
let's get to the villains remember how
much I liked Alexandra and how much
weight Sigourney Weaver brought to the
part and made her a compelling villain
well they just decided to jettison that
I don't know where it they did they did
the exact
same thing with Luke Cage by killing
cottonmouth in the middle of that season
and then replacing him with another
villain we heard reference but I hadn't
met before and were suddenly expected to
be invested in him was like but we just
spent the last six episodes getting
hooked into this guy you just killed and
they did the exact same thing with her I
spent six episodes getting engaged by
her finding or intriguing finding her
dynamic within the hand interesting
finding her desperation knowing that she
was dying interesting and a good
motivation for a villain especially
because the goals of the hand of Rawls
and organization are still pretty weird
and nebulous I'm going to come back to
that so who did they're an engine day
what it might have worked except then
they transition the villain to Elektra
here's why that is a complete and utter
failure they have not established over
the course of her appearances either in
the second half of daredevil or at all
on this show who Elektra is what her own
actual goals and desires are pretty much
the only thing we know about her is she
has an attraction and a pull to Matt
Murdock that's really about it because
in her end parents in daredevil season 2
she is there on sticks agenda so we
don't really know too much about her own
specific desires and once we just know
she's there you know meeting out what he
wants her to do and now in this her
becoming the black sky which is another
stupid wasted thing that we'll come back
to if I don't remember to and as I get
more rain tea about this but again she's
not there to pursue her own agenda she
is a henchman of somebody else so she's
not driven by own motivations now the
moment that she chose to kill Alexandra
while I am was immediately frustrated
because I'm like baby did this this
could be a bad point because we're
losing a good villain the motivation for
her to make that decision I got I was
there because Alexandra basically pushed
the one button on her that was was
absolutely the one she shouldn't push
she was like you need to kill the devil
of Hell's Kitchen well she's not going
to do that so she's going to kill you
now I was there for that but then
suddenly she takes over the hand
why why I have no idea I have no clue
why Elektra is doing anything I have no
idea what she wants I have no idea
what's motivating her I no idea how much
of this version of Elektra is actually
Elektra because it's like is she still
fighting with whatever programming or
whatever she had from being the black
sky is she now completely electric even
if she's now completely electric that
doesn't help because she was pretty
ill-defined last season as well like I
said because she was mostly there on
other characters and Genda so you're
suddenly going and now this character's
the villain I'm like but I don't
understand her well enough I honestly I
understood Alexandra way better than I
understood Elektra certainly in terms of
motivation and why she was doing
anything so to have ally to have
Alexandra drop dead and Elektra come in
and take over the villain role
absolutely does not work and the entire
black sky thing like what what what is
the black skies supposed to be it is as
vaguely defined at no it is even more
vaguely defined than the Iron Fist is
because it's just like so it's a weapon
of the hand but like she's not even that
great a fighter okay she kind of holds
her own but she gets her butt handed to
her repeatedly by both individual and
collective members of the defenders yes
fine she's able to take out stick and
take some of them down but that's like
after some of them are drug Denis unlike
she never feels like any kind of
ultimate weapon so is there more to the
black sky than just being a good fighter
hmm we didn't get an explanation on that
either like what about the black sky
maid Alexandra poor the last of their
resources their ability to continue to
live forever into making her I don't get
it can you don't explain to me what
frigging thing is the whole mystery
surrounding the hand has really huh it
hasn't worked up to this point the few
answers we got are helping so I said
before I now understood the structure of
the hand so the five fingers of the hand
they were kind of independent unless
Alexandra pulls them all together that I
got and that still works in terms of
explaining sort of a hierarchy in terms
of the organization but in terms of its
goal
this is still very ill-defined in a few
things that I get like spec up that
doesn't answer anything that doesn't
explain anything so like their their
motivations seem to be more or less
twofold they want to live forever and
they also want to get back to come one I
don't know why they want to get back to
come on there's it's never made clear
what it is they would do what they were
at Kunlun which means that all the
motivations for as much collateral
damage as they may be causing and as
much damage as their criminal
organizations tend to cause their actual
ultimate goal of getting back to come
one I don't understand why that's a bad
thing
I had nothing but the show's word that
that would be a very bad thing why why I
still don't understand the value of
Kunlun even to the good guys much less
what the bad guys would you when if and
when they got there there's no
indication that they're looking to take
it over destroyed they're just like we
want to get back to come on
why just tell me something tell me
anything know why anything with this
group well I just don't understand like
this is why Alexandra worked because her
motivations were brought down to
personal she is dying I can get behind
that
I don't have to mess with any crazy BS
mythology that isn't working that is
direct that is personal I get that
motivation so the instance they dropped
her and I'm now stuck with the more
vague motivations that were either
ill-defined or so straightforward by
something that is very and that is also
a little to find in there in terms of
the gold what they're trying to get then
now it's all Sun doesn't work anymore
the instance she dropped dead the show
fell apart and how big is the hand as an
organization like let's say heroes go
into this building to blow it up and
this is this is at a point where the the
other members of the hand the three that
are still alive don't have their magic
resurrection juice whatever the heck it
is so they show up in the car park to
fight them directly
I remember thinking
God are they out of henchmen like why
would they why would they risk their
necks wet their most vulnerable facing
these out and it got even stupider
because later weather like mining the
dragon bones or whatever we see they
still have henchmen that got them
working on the six what why were they in
garage fighting them themselves that is
the stupidest thing that could possibly
be doing so once we no longer had a
personal motivation for our head villain
we're back to this negative wheeler
scratch the villain stopped working and
that all went to hell so now I don't
have any investment actually actively
stopping these bad guys because what
they're harvesting dragon ball so they
can came to you to live something
they've been doing for hundreds of years
and so they can continue to do general
criminal vaguely defined stuff I mean
good Wilson Fisk
works as a villain not only because he
was a wonderful and magnificent presence
but we understood immediately the kind
of damage that he was going to do to
this neighborhood that daredevil cared
dearly about the reason cottonmouth
works as a villain was because we knew
the damage he was doing to Harlem this
neighborhood that Luke ate scared about
the reason killed ray Ward's was because
he was doing direct damage to our hero
we saw it it was immediate it was
personal we understood the damage the
damage that the hand does as an
organization is so ill-defined it's just
yo oh they're an evil organization they
shouldn't be allowed to good thing it
was like could you give me something
tangible please I really want this to be
it for the hand I want them to close out
the hand as an organization as a plot as
like no more no more it hasn't worked it
has we big gotten further into it it is
continued not to work I don't think is
recoverable just drop it like I said the
heroes themselves are pretty good Danny
still the worst but he's certainly more
tolerable here not going in no small
part to the fact that other characters
regularly beat him up and call him a
dumbass
which makes me smile but they still
hinge a lot of the plot on him which I'm
not
I'm not particularly thrilled by I feel
like they really underutilized well
honestly I think they underutilized
boasts both Jessica and Luke I think
Jessica most severely which on the one
hand seems weird because Jessica and
Luke Cage I think were the most
intriguing and developed characters I
mean you regardless of what I think
about their series as characters they're
the ones who I like being around the
most and they kind of get the short
shrift in favor of daredevil carrying
all the emotional weight of a lecture
coming back and then Danny being so
disproportionately plot relevant to
everything so I think what we're seeing
is the downside to the Netflix model in
terms of these shows and also in terms
of trying to crank out as many of these
shows back-to-back as they have been
doing because you know it's very easy
and it's very common to pick on typical
network television you know the main
networks 20 to 24 episodes in a season
like Beatles there's too many you get
filler you stretch the budget in the
cast to thin that did that all valid but
there's one big advantage to that way of
doing which is that they're still
filming the show as the episodes start
to air which means they're able to gauge
and adjust based off audience reaction
so if if once the show starts airing
you're finding to go oh we're not liking
that character we are liking that
character then as as the season is still
going on they can beef up certain
characters make corrections to others
drop characters if need be as the show
is progressing when when these things
where they shoot an entire season and
air it as a bendable thing while it does
I suppose give it a sort of an innate
artistic purity to it when you're trying
to make something crowd-pleasing
which these shows are as opposed to
something that is strictly a 100 percent
unique artistic vision then honestly I
think there is a real benefit to that
immediate audience feedback that which
shows like this you can only do between
seasons and as we see as I think we're
seeing now the way they overlap the
different shows that it doesn't allow
for much in the way of course correction
and I think in a way the Marvel Netflix
shows kind of fell into the same trap
that the DC EU has and is that the DC U
is now in the process of digging itself
out of which is that they laid down too
much work and built too much momentum
off of unproven stuff so the time that
this is that this whole grandeur
universe thing has worked has been
Marvel's movies that's where it's worked
pretty much unequivocably and that's not
again that's not me saying every movie
is brilliant but the reason it works is
because each individual series is not
overly dependent on the others they come
together for the Avengers but their
individual series for the most part are
pretty standalone and they are
especially standalone when they first
start you look back at phase 1 and you
know Thor Captain America Iron Man I
Incredible Hulk all of these very much
completely stood on their own and by the
time they got to the Avengers they were
able to gauge what the reactions to all
of those are and make adjustments like
recasting hope and reworking that
character again but if any one of those
films or series starts to go off the
rails
it doesn't knock the other ones out of
alignment they've integrated the Marvel
Netflix shows much tighter together much
earlier in the process so now the Marvel
films have started to get a little bit
more integrated but it was only after
every franchise was like really on solid
footing so here what they did was they
is with the most recent - especially by
the time Iron Fist aired they were
already were shooting if not had already
finished shooting the defenders so how
bad the reception on Iron Fist was and
how much people did not like Danny Rand
couldn't be adjusted for in the
defenders because it was at the very
least already written by then if not
already shot or in the middle of
shooting I didn't bother to recheck the
schedules but it had to be written back
to back which was the same problem I
mean it's a big part of why Justice
League is going through made
yes I'm aware of the other stuff going
on but the first word of reshoots long
before Zack Snyder had to drop out of
that movie came on the back of the fact
that it started shooting pretty much
immediately after Batman V Superman was
in theaters which means they were
working off a script that assumed
audiences would love Batman V Superman
and audiences were very split on Batman
V Superman but there was no chance to
adjust the script for Justice League
before I started shooting could they
already had too much momentum and I
think we're seeing the same thing right
now with the Marvel Netflix shows
because they really seem to assume that
Danny Rand would be better accepted than
he actually was and they put him front
and center on this and all and also in a
way repeating the same structural
mistake that they did with Luke Cage
which was to jettison the villain that
they'd gotten us invested in in favor of
in favor of another one and they'd do
the same mistake here and normally I go
how can you be doing the same say oh the
productions were too close together by
the time they realize it's a mistake
it's too late to fix it in the next
thing so I don't know how integrated the
various shows are going to be with each
other
going forward I mean hopefully this this
is this is going to be kind of it
because really there hasn't been a ton
of aside from certain characters hasn't
been a ton of crossover across the
different shows but in terms of like
coming together for a blowout equivalent
of the Avengers this fall's well well
short of that it's still better than
iron fist but I think that's the only
thing it's better than much like
daredevil
much like Luke Cage it starts out good
and then has a weaker second end I think
the difference is that this fall's much
harder on its face than those other two
did those other two had a dip in the
second half of their seasons in both
cases but this one this thing just
face-planted ad in episode 6 and yeah
that was kind of it so that's it for the
defenders Wow
freaking disappointment by the time it
wrapped so did you get through the whole
thing what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts were drop
something down in the comments
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter I
counsel geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I'm also one half of
the punch like the girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]